Homeless people and they shipped him out there and buses.
They could vote from the town that gave them jobs and identities and these
people were extremely happy.
That was what?
It was crazy.
It's like a,
I'm sure up.
Some of them were troubled,
but for a lot of them they finally had a sense of purpose.
They just been taken into this place as family.
So they made Utah,
they basically made a town in Utah.
I've always respected and what I did see part of this movie geek at three in the
morning like,
Oh shit.
Why is it that white hippie like people trust Brown people with beards so much?
Well,
they want to believe in enlightenment and in all the media portrayals of
enlightenment and all of,
you know,
when people talk about mystical experiences,
they had an India.
It's always that part of the world that emphasizes spirituality.
And the idea that the Hindu religion is a,
is a,
a more ancient,
more Comcast's spiritual religion as a,
as to the Indian Yogi figure is the white Jesus figure of white people 100%.
So for why people who don't know white Jesus in the black community is a
mythical creature that has enormous power,
right?
It's insane for anyone to believe in a deity that doesn't look like them.
Right?
So,
but in the black community we're just in love with renaissance paintings and
Jesus is why as fuck.
All right,
so we have the same infatuation that you're weird hippy art has with Indian men
with long beards and their mysticism.
We have that wear white jeans so that you've just helped me understand cause
I've always wondered like what the fuck is it up?
Well white people and east Indian people that cause Vikrum who directed trigger
warning also has a documentary where he creates a fake religion and convinces
you know,
white middle class people to follow.
That is a crazy one.
The white cheese.
This one,
right?
A white Jesus.
A motherfucker bro.
Like,
like,
man,
I'm going to get me a shirt that says white people want to stay woke.
And what I mean by that is Western civilization,
it's,
this is the latest phase.
Like people have to understand there have been many empires and civilizations.
There was a time where Mali in Africa and Kim and in Africa with the biggest
civilizations and colonizers on earth later,
Persia,
biggest cock,
like you've had systems.
And right now the West has just for the last thousand years or so has been
kicking and dominating ass.
A lot of what we see on the news between the West and what we call the Middle
East now,
what was wanting western per dre at western Asia,
this is thousands of years war.
You know,
you're hearing Islam versus Christianity,
but it's really two ideologies that have been fighting for thousands of years
over how the globe should be governed.
So with,
with that shit man,
it's like there's no,
there's no stopping this shit and split white.
Jesus springs out of that and kind of goes everywhere and colonizes everything.
So you know,
the church pops up.
We candy for kids bibles for you.
And by the way,
we're going to be gone in a while,
but we're going to leave this guy here on the wall so you know what the ideal,
what God's son look like.
So if God's son looks like a dooby brother can sell this God,
God looks like Jim Morris,
Jim Morris with a full beard.
He's straight the fuck.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's really,
Jesus would probably a Tan guy with dark hair and curly curly hair and Brown
eyes that was saying shit that the government and the church didn't like.
So they knocked him the fuck off.
Yeah.
Why do you think that each race looks for someone of another race to be their
advisor?
Because I don't think people trust the divinity in themselves.
You know,
I think,
I think that once you understand that as human beings,
we really only looked different because of subtle differences and atmosphere and
changing.
You know,
who you mixed with win.
But I think that all those books that are moms paid Oprah to sell us of self
help and inward looking.
Reverend Ike had told my grandmother's generation ad in the seventies you know
what I mean?
And I think that we're scared to turn off the lights and at some point see
something divine within ourselves.
Because once you do that,
that requires you act differently.
And I think that people need to be told what to do.
Not that they actually need it,
but they want to be instructed,
you know,
versus knowing or going on a gut feeling or experiment and getting something
wrong.
You know,
my grandfather was one of the most kind moral men I've ever met.
He was always gentle with children.
He only put a belt on my butt twice in my life and shit.
I think he cried harder than that same man at 14 years old.
Shot a man in church for kicking the spike down.
You know,
he grew up in between 14 and 54 when I was born.
And he had experiences that he had learned to regret and he had dealt with that
and he had become something that by the time I was a child,
he was raising me.
My grandfather was divided in my eyes almost.
You know what I mean?
Not because he was perfect because he was genuinely good and moral.
But as a 14 year old boy who had grown up fatherless,
who dropped out of school in the third grade,
and who had,
who understood it,
that I must protect my mothers and sisters,
he refused to be bullied by anyone,
even an adult until the point of putting a bullet in him.
You know what I mean?
So I think that a lot of times we're afraid to see that divinity in ourselves
also.
Because then you have to acknowledge the darkness and you have to deal with
that.
And it's easier to get instructed by someone else and it's easier to see.
The evil is outside too.
It's easier to see.
That is something that I can't control.
It just happens versus I'm compliant.
I'm complicit in it.
You know?
That's,
uh,
it's also a consequence of,
you know,
one of the things that bothers me the most when people talk about people that
commit crimes or think about people that commit crimes.
So much of who a person is as a consequence of things that had nothing to do
with them.
Absolutely.
They get had been born in a terrible neighborhood to horrible parents,
been abused sexually and physically and,
and by the time you get to them that broke their life is already a mess.
It's a shambles row.
And for you to try to think that they are going to look at life and just figure
it out with no assistance whatsoever is,
it's crazy.
It doesn't work like that.
One of the weirdest things about our culture is that we haven't put more of an
emphasis in finding the spots that are
there,
the ghettos and the terrible neighborhoods in this country,
and figuring out a way to build them up and just make it even.
We know you're out away.
We know on unequivocably where jobs and commerce are precedent and economic
opportunity and prosperity occur,
Dessa,
dramatic reduction and elimination and gang violence.
Yet we do not put resources into building institutions that will create
entrepreneurs or work on a soft skill so the kids can be working at and around
production houses to the els.
We put that money into prisons.
Yeah.
And then we use prison labor to undercut things like call centers,
um,
things like that,
that jobs,
I mean factories may need and we are doing a disservice by doing that.
We,
and I always say we,
because we looked at our quote unquote leaders and blame them when so many times
we allow it,
you know,
we allow this to happen by not paying attention and not voting.
We allow it to happen by not raising our voice,
even though we know someone in prison and saying this is wrong.
You know,
the last people,
I don't believe just for the record,
I don't believe in the big three.
They Abrahamic religions,
I'm not into them,
but the books I've read and they're amazing graphic novels,
I of read them like I can look like a graphic novel of sorts.
Right.
And when you look at the people who Christ died with,
right?
It was,
he was,
he was up,
there were thieves.
The last person he saved before he got out of here was a thief.
I was like,
what's a confessed?
Steve was dying right next to him.
And he was like,
you know,
we're going to go on this together.
That sets an amazing things.
So as you're serving your savior,
your messiah,
you need to be thinking about who he spent this time with.
You know,
he was with liars and thieves,
he was in the streets,
he was with people who are alleged to be prostitutes.
And I think that if we start to turn our attention to those places and we put
our intentions and good there,
we do produce on the out on the other side better.
But as long as we look at religion to something that makes us holy,
makes us clean and washed us of our sins and we become pious in that,
I think religion will be something that's forever kind of harmful.
It helped to create that.
And I think that that,
that believing that some people are good or evil doesn't allow us to say,
well what could we do to fix those ghettos to fix those depressed areas?
Cause for every ghetto where I'm from,
for every ghetto that's in the city,
in the south,
I can show you a mountainous region with a trailer park that's just as bad for
sure.
And those and those.
And those kids deserve a life better than oxycontin addiction and turmoil and
pain to 100% yeah.